this is the danger this is the danger
miss me lad hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for tuning
in to the Dean show when we come back
we're going to be talking about who is
your best friend we all have best
friends in life people that we really
attached to people that we follow people
that we emulate or maybe we're
somebody's best friend so we want to
come back and talk about who is your
best friend is it a law or is it someone
other than the creator of the heavens on
earth will be right back here on the D
shop this is the theme the danger this
is the things is the danger
this is the pain this is the thing is
just Athene jus this is the angel
Salaam alaikum Salaam peace be with you
lover katherine you hamdullah Thank You
hamdullah praises to the crater of
heavens and earth who's given us his
ability to be here and to talk about
something is very important what sort
though the topic today we're going to be
discussing best friends now when I
introduced a tapa I was like who was
your best friend some of my thinking and
I said you know is a law your best
friend someone think how am I gonna be
friends will follow that's the crater
the heavens an herb is is this something
that's not practical to make a law your
best friend okay lets me learn from the
last letter seminar so Allah it's
nothing wrong to have friends okay and I
don't think we can make it in life
without friends but there is a
difference between a friend and the best
friend and your wife can be a friend
your husband can be a friend your
neighbor can be many people can be your
friends but the reality when you're
talking about who is the best friend
this is a different issue this is the
ultimate friend yes bastard i'm sore on
talks about what are the love
rahimahullah that a lots of Hanover
Tyler took Abraham the Prophet Ibrahim
as a intimate frame and the koran talks
even about the Prophet Muhammad Sal
Allahu Liman various lady is who muffled
roar is the coolest ahi me that isn't in
na loja man there's a prophecy allah
salam who migrated have to run away and
leave Mecca because the non-believers
tried to kill him and him and abubakar
only and he went they hide in the cave
so he was saying to his friend don't be
sad Allah is with us ok Allah is with us
so if Abu Bakr is the friend of the
prophets a prophet is a friend of bugs
raise a higher position here that the
one who always be easier with you when
somebody tell because Mecca is the town
of the prophets
los alamos were he born when he grow
okay but for a certain time this
friendship stopped and the people turn
against him so you can understand how
things it change if it's a wife is a
children so things and even if your wife
is the best friend or your husband is
the best friend sooner or later they die
they leave you and after this he said
because he left the same but Almighty
Allah is the best friend and the only
friends that always can be there it's
important and the Quran say allah ma li
you'll edina MN o allah is the friend or
the best friend the garden the protector
of those who believe and what is the
most important thing your horizontal
domitila moon he takes them out of the
darkness to the light so the guidance
okay if something is very important and
the guidance has two types that you can
grab people by talking and guide people
biker ninja arts you as my friend you
can try to convince me to be a Muslim or
to carry the same ideology you have but
you could not turn my mind on my heart
accept it but Allah is the only one he
can guide through his revelation and
also we have the control the turn in
your heart to make you except disease so
he's the best friend friends are very
important as you said you know it's
nothing wrong with having your wife as
your friend your husband your friend but
now sometimes we excuse me let's correct
something we tokin when you say your
husband because when I say I say your
wife and you said to your husband maybe
somebody will misunderstand the things
that Muslims they can have this kind of
relationship gays and whatever no
talking about speaking in people in
general I think it's very important to
make it here because we don't believe in
this stuff yes yes yes oh you so what
time is it right yes absolutely so now
we see that many friends and if you have
the wrong friends you can get letter
string exam people they don't want to
practice yes the way of life that
the messengers of God practice its last
submission to the One God acquiring
peace by doing all the wonderful things
he told you so they're nervous they're
scared because they're scared what their
friends might say exactly these are the
wrong friends or you got a sports sweet
ballsy have impact in you and
subhanAllah the prophet muhammad
sallallahu LMK had indicates this long
time ago see metal jealous of Sally or
jealousy sooo gay bear miss Gore
national kill the the friend or the
companion or the gathering of a good
companion and bad companion like a
person who sell perfume and the bad
companion or frame is like the person or
blow in the furnace if he said besides
somebody who's selling perfume he
smelled something good it has some
impact in you okay but if he said in the
shop of the blacksmith's and he blow in
the furnace he can burn your clothes so
you have to watch and Reza saying say a
Sahib Sahib Sahib saying that mean your
friend can pull you like a tow truck ok
he has this ability that he can make you
go straight or make you go to the right
way wrong friend and this was happening
under you know how many Muslim women on
a stop button here because they you
consider Oh what was my friends and what
my schoolmate going to say about me
because it has impact to them and same
thing how many people they became Muslim
because he have the right frame so it is
very important and don't forget your
wife also part of this companionship and
friends as a result of this a prophet
salallahu I'm saying transferability the
interim acadec marry a woman because her
religion otherwise he'd be a loser
because she spent more money and more
time or not more money hey more time
with you and she going to have impact on
your children so make sure you get the
proper wife for your future generation
so we have to be careful about friends
but nevertheless is still the best
friend no one other than Allah because
he always going to be there for you
everybody else they may die you may get
angry they stop they may go away so even
left us no friends but the
the heavens and earth my lobby was there
before the creation going to be there
when it ends course and that's the one
we got to put our certainty reliance on
exactly one guy a lot and right to a lot
I'm do they let let's take a break shake
I'll be right back with more here on the
D show when the outside everything looks
good you see the hundred-thousand-dollar
car you see a lot of diamonds you see a
lot of females and they think that this
is you know this is a life this is this
is like no paradise right here which is
my job to go into someone's hard to
change their heart your job is to topi
what the truth is and the alley of it is
while we're sitting here while i'm
sitting here constantly paying for the
disease to kill was free i am not afraid
to stand alone its allies by my side i
am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand back here on the Dean
show we're talking about who's your best
friend now what we trying to impress
people but when you want to impress your
true best friend Allah then you're not
going to take the hijab off you're not
going to be worrying about impressing
other people who can lead you astray in
a way actually they can lead you to the
displeasure of the crater and they can
lead you towards the Hellfire the
problems that you don't have the real
love for your Creator because if you
have the real love for your Creator and
you want to be loved by your Creator
this will be your priority you don't
worry about who's happy with you who's
mad at you your concern is my lord my
Creator happy with me or not this has
have to be your priority is there one
authentic saying by the last and final
messenger sent to mankind the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him that says if
a person you know at this pleasure of
the evil yes at the pleasure of people
at the expense of losing a la la will be
displeased with that person and make the
people displeased with them can you yes
go ahead and wrap it under and for you
you understand to try to please Allah
regardless was in for other people Allah
will be pleased with you and he will
turn the hearts of the people to be
pleased with you but if you try to win
the pleasure of the people this reason
Allah Allah displeased with you and
still this we were going maybe smile at
your face for now but maybe a day to you
be something different you can't make
everybody happy exactly you're always
gonna do what you have to worry about
somebody like you okay you're my bean
doesn't matter was he wearing what's
their height what is every color I human
being like you see are weak if it gets
sick he understands or is it dies it
could not help themselves so why I'm
bought in these people to be as main
priority why this is because I have
something wrong with me I did not set my
priority there's a deficiency maybe
man any man who favors of course because
he still value people more than the
Creator but if you have a la the crate
tour as your best friend you're going to
have the best manners you're going to be
the most educated aren't you you can
have the best character exactly then
people at the end gonna love you anyway
of course this is true and don't forget
that the when you love somebody when you
be a friends because you love the person
admire the person this is a feeling
inside the heart you have to understand
who control in the hearts the human
being could not control their hearts a
las panatela is no no control the hearts
so you have to be concerned about the
one who have the control if you fix your
relationship between you and him now he
will take care of letting the people
love in you happy with you all these
things so we have to set our priority
who's like the one I want to please
that's the biggest one of the biggest
problem especially with the piers even
it goes towards the adult fitting in you
just want to fit in at any expense it
and this will cost you enjoy it's very
it's going to cost you because at the
end you'll be a loser you're gonna lose
the hereafter because you're going to
definitely lose this life believe me
those people who try to please them see
be the fairest one displeased with you
give it our time and this happen many
times okay in families and friends in
schools and jobs okay the turns are back
to you and this is reality everybody can
relate to this best friends and the
worst enemies exactly but Allah would
never turn his back is a bra fasala
lancel I'm teaching us they're all when
you love somebody love him you
understand gradually or easy don't fall
into this loves that when something
haven't you could not even I could not I
could not make it okay like somebody
puts a pair of my wife my girlfriend we
don't believe in but ya understand for
the public some people talk only
marriage in Islam oh he also has a wide
no dating tests exactly exactly but
whatever you call y 4 is equal it again
friend whatever is it okay so if
something happen is this person now she
feels that no need for life you go jump
in the river they commit suicide ya
understand why be
cause they did not have the right
understanding who's the ones that need
to be loved and seeking their love you
see so all these things is temporary and
it doesn't work let's take a break and
we're going to be right back with some
ways on how you can get a lot of love
what's the ways to go about it when we
come back here on the Dean show there
always be someone that will be there to
say something negative but at the same
time there'll be someone there to say
something positive awesome just hold on
to the Rope of Allah everything in this
universe rely I need a last minute the
Quran says don't kill women don't kill
children don't feel old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told it will fail you
mock you know Allah so that the Prophet
SAW shall have never ever start a war
against any of us so if you find
yourself your Iman is going down check
yourself there is nano woody to be
worship except Allah alone you got some
serious of music in the car Bobby you
had the fifty cents oh no it's common
sense don't do things that can hurt
people Lady Gaga googoo and all that
other nonsense blue Inga's head on back
biting slandering and such subsistence
as smoking state route 18 inch biceps
we'll see what happens to Eddie on the
Dean show
and we hold it down in a green shell
early make sure you are tuning back here
on the Dean show with Sheikh Mohammed
oddly shake tell us now okay we know
that we said earlier that your friends
they can have a great impact on you
mm-hmm they can help you get closer to
life their righteous friends exactly or
if they're friends who are corrupt
they're going to the night clubs you
know all they're thinking about is
fulfilling their lusts and desires and
you're trying to fit in you're going to
go with that bunch you're gonna you're
going to end up getting corrupted listen
to it give a little bit explanation
about a friends here that you supposed
to be that is as a Carter a hanok what
is an asset of the Kirk the friends that
you take from the human being the ones
that when you remember Almighty God he
will assist you if you forgot about the
remembrance of God he will remind you
yes that's at least if you don't have
this type of person this is better to
stay away yeah because he's going to
have an impact in you it's going to
corrupt you sooner or later so now as
example I say Oh Eddie we did not praise
or it spreads on so instead of say yes
let's praise or say what about if we go
and vote as a mask and plate and
congregation good friend you see this is
a good friend and if I forgot you would
remind me but here is a problem that you
have phrased nowadays they approaching
you okay about going the things let's
smoke let understand have girlfriends
let's go to the why you got this job on
your head take it out savvy I don't want
a coke like it don't fit you on the so
we're the 21st century now why are you
wearing this on your head you need to
wear a short skirt let the boys whistle
at you wrong friends this look this is a
bad company can you equate it now same
full of different quality of my friends
can you equate it to if you're trying to
again we go back to some of the world
example you want to get a big degree you
want to be a doctor a scientist an
engineer and you have a good friend
reminding you don't cut class come to
school and be on time that's a good
friend it's the same thing exactly
exec the other friends that encourage
you during the photo looking after you
understand things but other people say
Amen let's go watch TV let's go and the
cells cut class of fun exact not a good
friend this is not sort of Zara the same
thing okay tell us shake now tell us
tell us please how can we have a laws
our best friend what will make us earn
the pleasure of our Creator so that
you'll love us and we'll be there but
he'll be our best friend this this is a
big subject but basically if you can
look in the Quran if you look in the
index word love if I'm because by the
way a lot of questions they think that
Islam is about dude on and this is there
is nothing called love and you always
say to you Jesus is love God is love
love is a feeling God is not a feeling
God is a creator so the criminology even
is wrong God is not love ok but God
Almighty loves and he loves us exactly
so in Quran if you found in the index
and try to find the word love you will
find a lot of verses talks about acts
which may god almighty loves you as
example in allahabad away been away a
promoter Tahiry indeed Allah loves those
for a pain comes back to him stop
sinning and come back Allah loves him
and your hypnotic arrange those who
purifies himself physically mentally
spiritually he understands he always
saves himself to be clean purifies
himself staying away from the wrongdoing
from the bad mouthing okay from impurity
a lot of this okay so you found
description of people whom allah subhana
allah loves in allah is at a loss of
Hannah Tyler he loves us was build in
his cause Josie understand who care for
others and you found this is a lot in in
an Islam but one of the main things that
getting closer getting closer to God
okay and there is many many many ways
and make it means you have to fulfill
the obligation fairies the five-time
prayer is resting Ramadan making the
Hajj give it as a care but after this
higher degree now and this one will show
you the result of the love o mighty God
what well as a lab the attacker Abu Ayub
in our PhilHealth or him for either i
were to open to someone hilarious my way
what was her only observe a hadith qudsi
almighty allah saying that my slave
servant continued getting closer to me
by going optional deeds addition more
charity not only the care morson a
prayer not only five-time prayers ok
when you do extra optional deeds on
Michael I will love you and he's saying
when he loves the slave several days he
became the ears that you hear was the
eye which you watch with the hand you
touch with that mean God Almighty will
be there for you to guard all your names
so you be directed by your Creator so
you don't find yourself doing the wrong
thing now he became a shield for your
earring for your side so you always know
either good things and of course when
you are loved by Allah you know what was
the reward if you love somebody ready to
give him anything yes so can you imagine
if Allah loves us that's amazing that's
the love that you want this what it is
yeah you can live on love if you have
the love of Almighty Allah you don't
need anything else but it's not just a
take take roulette you gotta give back
to going tell us you're almost out of
time just a few more points i want to
put in tell us so the person you
mentioned that is fornicating you know
jumping from man to man woman to woman
you know swearing cursing doing evil
things dressing dressing promiscuous and
maybe a name it just doing drugs and you
know that person obviously is not
earning the pleasure of allah and your
furthering yourself away from a lot but
the one who did all that but you said
comes back they can be still the best
friend with the law it's not only the
best friend there is a hadith but was
supposed a short time there's a problem
said that Allah Almighty Allah is so
heavy more heavy yard than one of you
lost his camel with everything more in
the camel in
of the desert okay and he keeps
searching and he could not find the
camel so he gave up and say let me die
now and waiting for death he closed I
take a nap closed his eyes wake up he
sees a camel he's on behold the camera
say allahumma and tab do another book oh
god you are my slave I am your God that
the man was so happy he doesn't even
have to put the words together correctly
so instead of say thank you God he say I
am your garden my slave so Allah is so
heavy much heavier than this man who
find his lost camel with all the food so
whenever you come back to Allah Allah
welcome you I'm not happy that you come
back and he doesn't need you yeah but
this is the love of God and the reason
he can be your best friend can you make
that analogy because some people they
think desert camel never been there
never done that but if somebody lost
their whole bank account in a wallet and
now everything credit cards their whole
life savings is in like a box up he's in
the middle of the desert there is no
9110 understands it or in a ghetto and
he lies thinking he's never get his wife
so that gives it back he's the same
thing is much more than that yes allows
more happier when you repent and church
change your life for the better my so
happier but he doesn't need us yeah but
this is the two shows you why he can he
have to be a bit different because even
after Sinan coming back still welcoming
you closing comments and suggestions for
those that are having a hard time their
influence in the wrong way instead of
the right way but they want a lot to be
their best friend whatever I should go
through I tell them make a u-turn make a
u-turn and make a u-turn and come back
to Allah and Allah subhana Allah is
waiting in you at any time doesn't
matter day or night and if you can cry
one team from your eyes this will wipe
the whole thing great advice thank you
very much may Allah the Creator that
happens i reward you again for being
with us taking shape beautiful advice
make a u-turn you know if you're going
in the wrong direction the right
direction the signs out there you got to
watch this show if you're just trying to
fit in fitting with this crowd that
crowd you see
you're not happy you never content
you'll never be content until the dirts
in your mouth until you're in the grey
and now you know what the drama of this
life it's over but the drama and the
next has just begun don't get caught by
surprise by Milla como the angel
definite snatches your soul and you
spent your whole life trying to please
the people at the expense of displeasing
the one creator Allah work now to please
your Creator and let Allah be your best
friend that's how you can truly be
successful not only in this life but
definitely in the next and that's what
we're striving for it to be the best in
this life and to have the best paradise
in the next continue to tune in to the
Dean show every week we're here and
share the Dean show with all your
friends colleagues neighbors pick up the
DVD you can go ahead and make copies of
it and share this message of peace peace
acquired by submitting your entire self
your will to the will of the one God
will see you next time here in the den
show until then peace be unto you I am
not afraid to stand alone its allies by
my side I am not afraid to stand alone I
am not afraid to stand alone its allies
by my side I am not afraid to stand
I am not afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid of stand-alone you have to pray
as if everything depends on a lot and it
does but you must work everything
depends on you and it doesn't that's my
point you see on the same and I don't
like that I don't like us sitting here
what are you waiting for what are we
waiting for right now what are you
waiting for all these people to come to
this law what are you waiting for what
are we waiting for right now when
they're gonna come they're gonna come
along and bring these people lost upon
the water put in our hand the ability to
do it now do your job